it's a result against the left's radical
identity politics agenda all across the
country
remember that new jersey school district
that yanked all holiday names off the
calendar just to avoid hurt feelings
well
they just reversed course concerned
parents say they're being smeared as
quote right wing fanatics after calling
out the school board
they've brought shame and notoriety upon
our idyllic town so after you
overturn this idiotic decision you will
resign
all of you will resign today you've
managed to wake up
the entire community of randolph this is
a flash point
we draw the line in the sand you have a
reach
in loudoun county virginia the epicenter
of the pushback against critical race
theory
the school board there is meeting for
the final time this year tonight
parents telling school officials they
won't be silenced
this is about a parents movement to take
back our schools
to get a seat at the table with how our
schools are
run you have special interests you have
activists that's the only groups they
seem to listen to
whereas parents show up every day to try
and make their voices heard and we get
ignored
and in colorado a mayor there tried to
suspend the pledge of allegiance at
school board meetings due to unspecified
reasons
but attendees recited it anyway
due to direct and indirect threats
inappropriate comments and out of public
meetings
and the general divisiveness that she's
creating in our community
uh we will not be doing the pledge of
allegiance during town of silverton
board of trustee meetings
but it's just been done for a long time
we all took an oath
and we as a board collectively decided
it would be done
uh this is not up for discussion at this
moment oh not up for discussion dana
do you really think it was divisive the
pledge maybe one person
said they didn't like it yeah maybe they
got like a tweet right a tweet and
there's a panic um
when this everybody attending the
meeting stands up and says the pledge
anyway at the end that guy the moderator
he says
that's out of order um i think that we
are showing examples all across america
first of all
of what it's like to actually attend a
school board meeting i was talking to a
guy
the other day he was at one of the
randolph meetings he said never go to
school board meeting
my life and now they've gone to several
of them and you see
american parents all across the country
saying wait what's going on in my school
district and showing up at school board
meetings which is actually i think
very healthy you want people to be more
energized and engaged and possibly
you'll see somebody
you know like like an ian prior i'm not
speaking for him i don't know but you
could imagine that
because he has awoken this movement in
loudoun county virginia
perhaps he'll run for a school board you
always like ask yourselves like well
would you want to run would you want to
run like and actually getting into the
arena is one of the
important things uh the average american
is
more patriotic more moderate more um
much less partisan than the me any media
conversation would have you think
and that's where the action is greg
school board meetings
yeah i mean look i i'm a little
pessimistic i think it's too late
i mean um these are we have three
examples here when you have three
examples you have a segment
right it's like if there were two we
wouldn't have done this
but we had three and i applaud it and i
these people are brave but i think it's
too late i think the indoctrination is
present
in our culture our entertainment
industry academia
and also our corporations have you seen
a typical hr email lately we won't
mention it
but the language is directly lifted
from academic identity politics lexicon
it has it is everywhere you look i don't
think i've seen anything spread so fast
in my life
and it preys upon these two uh the two
flaws of human nature one of them is
fear people are terrified of being
ostracized or losing their jobs or both
which is why you see students parroting
this woke
babble from their teachers and you see
corporate execs embracing the
diversity platitudes and why
entertainers are so desperately
waving the blm flag it's because they
they'd rather you not
look in their past for any sexual
indiscretions that's fear but the other
thing is that
uh fear causes people to blend in right
this is why human beings imitate each
other's behavior
uh they don't want to stand out that was
the whole re that was that was the
method for survival
so if you don't want the woke after you
then you parrot the woke
right it's memetic camouflage so that
that's why i believe
that this stuff is spreading and i don't
know how to stop it because
fear and and and just wanting to belong
is letting it happen and it's happening
all around us
that's why these things are i'm glad
they're there at the school board and
maybe that's where the fight has to
happen because it's visual
and people will be persuaded by it but i
think about like
are we going to have a fight with our
corporate hr no are
are people going to fight their at the
principles at their school well i guess
they are
but at the colleges are they going to go
after entertain i don't know
i for one think our hr department does a
bang-up job
i was using it as a generation but i do
i think you're right about
corporate america they've surrendered to
the woke people but
i i disagree on the school board front
dagin
i think parents are very outraged and
they're not going to put up with it
anymore and that's where they're getting
traction and that's why we're showing
this and and that's where the change
begins to happen because the people who
are working in hr at these major
corporations who are making marketing
decisions
purely for the fringe left
they they were indoctrinated through
college
and that's what that's who's working in
these corporations now so if you start
at you know high even the grade school
level the high school level
but to data's point most americans
are go along get along kind of folks who
really try to avoid controversy
they work their asses off they've got
they're dealing with their families and
their friends
and church and maybe they want to go
fishing once every few
months they really don't have time for
this nonsense but all it takes
is one small group of trifling
sanctimonious jerks to set them off and
i call it the reverse
domino theory so instead of falling down
one by one you have one per it just
takes
one person to stand up one outraged
parent
one or citizen speaking up and then 10
more will stand up because they feel
supported
and they get loud and that's how change
happens and this is not
they're trying to paint it like these
are conservative parents and
conservative individuals
no way you start to look at who a lot of
these people are
they are across the spectrum of races
and socio-economic groups but they see
their children being
indoctrinated into hate it's like you're
talking about an
educational tea party yeah grassroots
yeah that's where the action is richard
i assume you agree with everything that
was just said
listen i spent my afternoon reading some
of these critical race theory bills
um because i think that reading is
fundamental and i've never heard of that
wow
and you know what i was dismayed because
some of not only are these bills poorly
worded and vague in their writing but
some of these bills make literally no
sense
right one the bill in iowa bans the
teaching and i wrote it down
it bans the teaching of the following
topics sexism slavery racial segregation
uh well if it's in the bill did you that
is not true did you read it i i haven't
read the bill okay
i would bet no i will tell you something
i will bet then you cannot
find anything in the bill that says we
will not teach slavery
it's prohibited in iowa
no knowledge of the bill if that
actually was
in the bill it would have been the front
page of every newspaper
well it actually was in iowa but back to
what i was saying
the topic that occurring is sexism
slavery racial segregation
racial discrimination including topics
related to the enactment and the
enforcement of laws
resulting in sexism racial oppression
and segregation
that's like half of american history
yeah history is banned
excuse me history is bad so what that
actually means is if you're a student
a high school student in iowa and you're
studying for the american ap
history exam yeah you're likely to fail
because half of these topics won't be
taught okay so
good luck to the students
in 1776 they're not in tennessee from
1776
they can't teach history started
in 1965 actually actually if you really
don't know
if you're really specific they really
couldn't teach 1976 because abigail
adams letters to her husband about
remembering the women
would actually be illegal they don't
even start in seventeen years i'm just
telling you what the bills
start tonight which is part of the
problem in 1960 which is part of the
problem
you attack critical race theory and
actually not talk about what's actually
being taught in class which is the truth
about american history
we have this dilemma which is vaguely
poorly written
quickly written bills that make
absolutely positively no sense we will
find out
the truth about the bill in iowa and
then we will tell you
as soon as we find out hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else